zach says matt you're being too hard on  kim she may be wrong on this one topic  but she's really good on vaccines and  other subjects it's not fair to  completely dismiss her kim responded to  my tweet about dr scott mosser the  butcher who chops the breasts off of  adolescent girls  with this rebuttal it's their body their  choice there are topics  where i can disagree with somebody  and but i still respect them this is not  one of those topics if you cannot get  this right if you cannot at a minimum  understand  why it's wrong  to mutilate children chop their body  parts off castrate them if you can't  understand that  or for whatever reason are pretending  that you can't then i i i can't respect  you we have to have some kind of  fundamental shared value system for us  to be on the same side but if your value  system  allows you to defend that then there is  no way  our value systems are shared they're not  even in the same universe